[Music]
all right let's roll out to Fresno
California and talk to Lynn what's up
Lynn hello what's up I'm here hey Lynn
Hi how are you good what's
up okay uh this is a pretty big one um
so my question is uh were my
expectations too much and was I too
insensitive and and I'll give you a
backstory go for it on on what happened
so I recently got married uh in
September
and I had asked my best friend to be to
be my maid of honor which she said that
she would do so mind you she work she
lives in Oregon and uh we we've been
best friends for seven years we've lived
together um I'm a Believer and she's not
and so she moved to Oregon with her
boyfriend and they have a
six-month-old and um you know it's been
really hard for her moving up there
she's been financially strapped um so
with that we offered for her to uh come
down here we pay for a roundtrip flight
for her to come to attend the wedding so
it would make it a little bit easier on
her um so a month before my wedding she
calls and she tells me that she's not
going to come to the wedding and then I
found out that she was pregnant
unexpectedly with her second child
and she didn't really go more beyond
that on why she couldn't uh or why did
she she decided not to come and um I
just felt like there was more but as she
just wasn't telling me
um so I kind of distanced myself from
her during that time um because you know
I was obviously really busy in planning
a wedding and then just emotionally like
it really hurt me and I did express that
to her a little bit um and then I
reached out to her after the wedding
telling her more how it really hurt me
and that I just needed a little bit of
space to like you know pray and forgive
and move on and then she comes at me
with all of these reasons as to why it
was my fault that she didn't come she
was um I mean she was telling me that
she had a miscarriage which I didn't
even I wasn't even aware about um she
was telling me how financially strapped
they were even
more uh how unemotional how emotionally
she just wasn't capable of leaving her
child
and ultimately I didn't respond to her
right away which even set her off even
more and attacked me even more and and
when I did try reaching out to her
she just didn't want any she just didn't
want to talk to me and she wanted her
she needs her
space and I don't really know what to
think about this situation anymore
because I'm not trying to be insensitive
because one point I understand what she
was going through but I don't understand
why she wasn't telling me all that stuff
if I was her best
friend
yeah you might not have
been I'm sorry you might not have
been might not have been her best friend
yeah
well I mean we've I have been there for
her for the years that we've been
friends like over the top and she even
mentioned in her message that she
admitted sometimes our friendship was
one-sided that I I was a great friend to
her and you're not hearing what I'm
saying l
oh sh she might have been your best
friend but you might not have been
hers oh yeah I I understand that um
behavior is a language I say that a
lot and she made it clear
here that she didn't trust you enough to
sit to tell you what she was going
through that's not an indictment on you
I don't even know if that's an
indictment on
her but for whatever reason she gave you
her commitment and then she backed out
and she was unable to tell you why MH
and
then behavior is a
language she didn't want to talk to you
for a
while and then
she let you have
it yeah after you let her have
it and then and then and
then what I can't figure out is if
you're mad that you had this picture of
what this wedding was going to look like
and she messed your picture up because
she wasn't
there or if you're mourning the fact
that this friendship is
over or May be
both yeah I mean obviously it's not the
same with her with her not being there
and yeah I did imagine it in one way um
but OB I didn't know all that stuff that
was going on so I know but you didn't
know because she didn't tell you right
exactly which was confusing to me it's
not confusing it's very
easy
either you're not the friend she's not
the friend that you thought she
was or she didn't trust
you it's not
confusing it's not over dramatic it just
is it sounds very very
painful if one of my closest friends in
the world just called out of the ballue
was like hey man this big thing that's
happening for you I can't be there why
not I just can't
dude talk to me why I'm not going to
tell
you that'd be devastating to
me and I would have to make peace with
he gets to do
that and I'm not in super tight
relationships with people who don't
trust me it's
cool because I work really hard to be
trustworthy so if you don't want to
trust me okay I'm going to live in that
I'm going have be heartbroken for a
while that
happens
but you're giving her a lot of power
over your
life and I mean this in like in the most
loving way I can say it but you're
choosing misery right
now which is different than choosing
grief which is different than choosing
to move on you're choosing anger and
rage and
mad instead of choosing to be
heartbroken that your friend ship of
seven years almost a
decade it's it's gone now it's not what
it was going to
be yeah that is that's hard to swallow
for sure
yeah but that energy is much better
spent in
grief and working through what comes
next you're married now you're all going
to have a different kind of Life mhm you
live in different states
you're going to have to do the hard work
of making friends in your local
community your local area rebuilding
trust to people that you love there or
building it for the first time that's
where it's been my
energy because here's the deal doesn't
matter what I think about if you were
over the top about your wedding it's
what you wanted and you asked your
friend and she said I'm in then she
backed out and didn't tell you
why that hurts real
yeah it
does but if I'm you I'm not going to go
back another
time I'm just not yeah because you think
it's going to feel good when you finally
get those final words in and I'm telling
you right now it's going to be a hollow
Victory it won't feel
great
yeah that's what my husband's been
telling
me a it's the worst when he's right
isn't
it yeah I'm like what about this and
he's like nope he's like it's not going
to end that way you're not going to feel
any better you will not because you
already tried to get your mic drop
moment after the wedding was already
over you called and you told her what's
up and then she was like hold my beer
I'll Mike drop
you and then you were like hold on hold
both my be and this shot I'm going to
mic drop your mic what are we why what
are we doing yeah
yeah she told you I had this I had this
I had this I had this and oh my gosh you
didn't respond on my
schedule behavior is a language she's
telling you she does not want to have
the kind of friendship that you want or
need which sucks after all the does all
the years that I've does poured into it
I know but she's not a
401k you don't be nice to somebody so
that one day they're nice back to you oh
of course not yeah of course not but
that's what you did and you're mad that
your investment didn't pay
off instead of being heartbroken that um
you may have misread this relationship
for a long time or that you look up and
you realize oh this was super one-sided
she even called it out I was kind of a
sucker or man she called out how
one-sided this was I think I was super
nice to her all these years
because I didn't want to be
alone that's a way harder truth to
swallow than oh yeah I'll tell
you right
yeah you got to make peace with what is
owning choosing
reality reality is absent her calling
you and saying hey I blew it I totally
screwed up at a major
loss I don't like being I don't like
living where we
lived my relationship with my boyfriend
I thought it was going to be this cool
new hip modern way of doing love we
don't need marriage we're just gonna
have kids and we're gonna it's falling
apart I'm
broke I can't breathe I'm so scared and
I miss you and I took you for granted
she didn't call with that
sounds like you got to make peace with
this thing's over and that's going to
hurt but choosing rage and choosing
misery is not affecting her day one bit
it's just poisoning you and like the old
saying goes you're drinking poison
hoping that she gets sick and she's not
she's an Oregon doing her Oregon things
probably making her own granola and
whatever they do
Oregon and you are just
suffering so I'm going tell you I would
recommend choosing grief choose
heartache be sad write a letter that you
will never
send just get out of out of your body
onto a page write a letter says I'm
sorry that this didn't work out I really
really loved you poured into you I miss
you and I had this picture of us going
Side by decide right or die you're
you're relationship you're a couple
friends and it's not going to happen
you're going to miss out and I wish you
the best and then you got to go do the
hard work of making new friends in your
local
area and you're worth every minute of
it